le cinéma c'est souvent intéressés à
l'école mais le troisième et dernier
film france est entrée aujourd'hui en
compétition ne ressemble à aucun autre
toute l'équipe du film de laurent cantet
entre les murs c'est dépassé à cannes un
grand moment cette montée des marches
surtout lorsque l'on n'est pas un
comédien professionnel et qui on est
encore dans l'adolescence au collège la
joie d'être à cannes
à la veille du palmarès le reportage de
dominique poncet et laurent fabius
le professeur autoritaire comprennent
soutenir qu'on parle de vous dans la
presse nationale et surtout être là au
festival de cannes en compagnie des plus
grands professionnels de cinéma du monde
ces adolescents tous issus d'un collège
du 20e arrondissement de paris n'en
reviennent pas et pourtant c'est le
dénouement inespéré d'une aventure qui a
démarré pour l'été dernier quand on leur
a demandé de tourner dans un film tiré
d'un livre écrit par françois bégaudeau
sur son expérience de professeur de
collège en forme de vrai faux
documentaire ici et vous attendez qu en
faisant ça y est ça une force brute de
réalité simplement le réel ça se
fabrique on l'a fabriqué serait là on
l'a constitué la classe on a fabriqué
les scènes c'était de nous c'était oui
c'était de la fabrication il fallait que
je joue bas plus dans ce film dont tous
les personnages jouent leur propre rôle
ce sont des vrais profs qui incarnent
les profs et donc des vrais des lèvres
qui interprète et élèves
et tant pis si le film met le doigt sur
les lacunes et les travers de ces
derniers il s'assure
même ma grand mère et par année pas
comme le tournoi grand père il dit c'est
pas ça mais voilà une classe et sa
maintenance et plus enfin il ya de la
discipline mais c'est un peu de la
discipline relâché en la dia est l'exact
et l'ambiance elle exactement comme elle
est décrite en ciel
j'ai trop aimé trop nages ce qu'on ne
demandait pas d' apprendre dit et c'est
tout c'est de l'improvisation ans cassez
pas la tête et où franchement projeté ce
matin ceux entre les murs sélectionné in
extremis pour la compétition a
impressionné la croisette par son
extraordinaire justesse de ton
laurent cantet film une classe est dans
le champ de sa caméra apparaît soudain
tout le désarroi des adolescents
d'aujourd'hui ce qui rend sa chronique
non seulement passionnante mais
touchante à l'image de la montée des
marches aujourd'hui de toute l'équipe du
film